[Applause]
love you I love you thank you so much
are you kidding thank you for doing this
this is great this will make the whole
night special you know the druber it
gets you guys I heard I've seen the
Jeweler I'm happy to be in the druber
I'd like to start this with the
tradition have you ever farted under the
covers uh constantly a dutch oven I know
the Dutch oven I don't wave it if
Jackie's near me I don't I try to go
easy on her I pee now Drew literally
five at night I don't think that's
healthy but while I'm walking there I go
you know what let me take care of that
other thing doing that blast one out
well that is a perfect time
[Applause]
I don't even know how this happened I've
been hearing about being an old man ever
since that came out by the way I wanted
to do the cover of AARP you're too young
for that I'm too young too young you
little baby
if you had one movie that you had to
choose yeah one movie gets to represent
like you know when they put the Time
Capsule together like in 50 First Dates
I made you a tape every day remember
that no I don't remember that
oh you're good you're good yeah right so
what would be your one you only get one
so the movie that kind of sums up
everything yeah yeah
I worked with this young lady one time I
met her at The Newsroom Cafe she came in
she had stylish hair
pinkish
she came in we jammed on a movie idea we
got together we shot it we had the best
time ever and I'd want to see that one
and we call it
The Wedding Singer yeah I wasn't allowed
to sing Grow Old With You to Drew before
we sang it not at once I said I wrote
that that song I don't want to hear it
that's my reaction on film for the first
time I did that with forgetful Lucy too
that's right that's right
yeah oh forgetful
and then the Dolphins did the perfect
like heart dive so the Dolphins were
like oh we like it yeah let's give it a
good ending guys
say you go to the Past lives Pavilion
and you find out that you were someone
in history that makes you so psyched who
would you have been who was heroic
Lincoln would be nice yes that'd be
great great choice just did a lot of
great things for the world and he was a
lot skinnier than me
I'll go with Lincoln who would you be by
the way oh as the one I asked you that
no I hadn't thought about it I think
about it right now I know who you who
first words that come to Lizzie Borden
who is Lucy Borden Lizzy Borden was like
a famed killer Brian and she killed
people with an ax hello Lizzy no uh uh
who would you pick for real I feel like
I would have to be someone with a sense
of humor oh okay you could be Gilda she
was great sweet like you be killed that
yeah and her and cheating wife exactly
maybe we're kind of like Gene and Gilda
that would be pretty good Drew yeah
through that story
amen Bobby
say you work at Apple and the eggplant
Emoji has been Stripped Away because
everybody knows it's an emoji yes okay
and you have now got to pick the next
vegetable to slyly slide in as the new
Emoji which vegetable are you going with
I guess carrot or uh depending if I'm
feeling shy maybe the shrimp that's not
a restaurant
[Music]
can I introduce you to a very special
person Ronnie pleased to meet you good
to see you my man thanks for driving
Ronnie Ronnie is my mobile roomie he is
going to review hustle I will say it's
an exceptional movie thank you yes it's
very heartfelt it's motivating yeah
there's also a lot of life lessons in
there yes and this movie has made my
list of top three Sports movies yes and
Remember the Titans and Rocky are my
other two that's big I mean that means a
lot both those movies are incredible
thanks Ronnie I had a great time making
that thing and it was fun to make one
without Drew to be honest with you
Sadie and sunny you are so not invited
yeah Bob Mitzvah yeah best title that's
a good one yes did you wait until you
thought they were old enough because
they've always been doing cameos in the
movies yes just something that happened
it was pretty organic and they're very
that wasn't a part that was my that was
a foot noise
so am I one more
all right here you go
anyways
when this book came into our office and
everybody loved this idea and I mean
this is what they want to do they want
to act they like it and they watch good
acting and they love you and they think
I'm fine sometimes
my kids say to me what do you think your
best thing on your face is like what do
you thinking they go nothing but that's
kids Olive literally told me that like I
don't know how to write an s that my s's
I've always been horrible I remember
that back in the day I was gonna
originally change the title of Wedding
Singer to wedding anger go see your rest
your ass was pathetic remember when 50
First Dates was 50 First kisses yeah too
many yeses we had to get rid of it now I
know that you had hip surgery left one
when you send me the text of the picture
and your like leg was up yeah and you
you were watching the show yeah yeah
yeah I watched your show all the time
mornings I get to see you see how happy
you are how the energy you give off to
everybody to everyone on the show to the
audience you help me get the pilot we
did that you're in Cameron yep by the
way Cameron will you say hi to Cameron I
haven't seen Cameron in many years her
and I did discuss remaking Planes Trains
Anonymous when I was like well you know
Adam and I talk about that but yeah I'd
let you do that well also I want to play
John Candy well I you could do a good
candy you know who used to do candy the
best barley when he would walk around
the office and do lines from Planes
Trains you remember hanging out with all
of us at when I had some giant party at
my house I remember looking over the
balcony and it was like Spade Farley
Rock everyone the coolest people in the
world we're about to go into your sag
town hall right now I love you so we get
out come on Barrymore thank you thanks
Ronnie thanks guys
forget to leave me a review
[Applause]
and his beautiful family his gorgeous
wife Jackie and his beautiful daughter
sunny and Sadie you know I can't wait
for the you're so not invited to my bat
mitzvah and obviously if you haven't
seen it already because I know
everybody's been watching it and loving
it the spectacular movie Hustle that's
on Netflix now I think it's going to win
Adam award I think this is an
extraordinary it's one of the best films
I've ever seen him in and it is an
award-worthy performance it really
really is so thank you guys for watching
us in the drooper Adam I love you so
much
[Music]